[Música]
no os esperabais de esta verdad
pero me apuesto
a qué suenan estas fotos y seguro que
incluso algunos de vosotros las tenéis
en vuestras carpetas
pues la mía no era así la mía de hecho
era esta con recortes de periódicos
sobre la lluvia ácida o sobre la
reproducción del inigualable australiano
o el desastre del mar egeo en galicia y
es que con 12-13 años
ya sentía una gran empatía y curiosidad
por todo lo que me rodeaba
pero no os creáis que pusieron la imagen
inicial de gran show' el chico de la
moto de la foto inicial el fruto de la
casualidad porque la verdad es que
también me encantaba
y es que esto va de revoluciones pero de
la hormonal preadolescente pasamos a la
industrial
todos sabemos que el origen de nuestra
insostenibilidad como especie empezó
allá por el 1800 con la revolución
industrial cuando empezamos a utilizar
los recursos como si fueran infinitos y
en nombre de del progreso pues para que
os hagáis una idea de nuestro impacto
como plan como como ser humano en el
planeta solamente en españa' generamos
2500 kilos de basura al año por personal
dos mil quinientos kilos de los que más
del 60% acaban en los vertederos y es
que cada año superamos la biocapacidad
del planeta es decir la capacidad que
tiene el planeta de regenerarse y
globalmente estamos consumiendo los
recursos de 17 planetas
que el lenguaje coloquial quiere decir
que estamos viviendo muy por encima de
nuestras posibilidades
y esto ocurre porque nuestro sistema de
producción y consumo es completamente
lineal nosotros extraemos los recursos
producimos consumimos y tiramos y con
una población y una clase media
creciente tanto la cantidad de recursos
como que necesitamos como los residuos
que generamos pues es también creciente
y todos sabemos que esto tiene unos
impactos terribles en la naturaleza en
el medio ambiente y también en los seres
humanos y no humanos seguro que tenéis
en mente las imágenes de los ríos
asiáticos
llenos de colores motivados con
producidos por la industria textil y por
tantas otras industrias o los animales
atrapados en redes los animales marinos
o incluso de las tribus indígenas que
son desplazadas de sus tierras para
expoliar sus recursos y es que sólo en
40 años hemos terminado el 60 por ciento
de la fauna silvestre del planeta
como es posible que cuando destruimos
algo creado por el hombre lo llamamos
vandalismo pero cuando des construimos
algo creado por la naturaleza lo hagamos
en nombre del progreso
y es que este es el patrón típico de la
abundancia en el que aceptamos de forma
natural una actitud de despilfarro y
consumimos los recursos hasta el extremo
pero tengo que deciros que ésta no esté
no esta es la realidad como sabéis no y
ahora vamos a ver por qué
o suena esta imagen verdad la tabla
periódica que estudiábamos en el colegio
y que muestra todos los elementos
químicos de lo que existe en el planeta
pues la plata el hidrógeno el oxígeno el
flúor
según la sociedad americana de química
44 de estos 118 elementos
están en riesgo de desaparecer durante
este lo que queda del siglo hoy existe
una disponibilidad muy limitada
cada uno de los teléfonos que llevamos
en nuestros bolsillos ahora mismo
contienen 30 de estos minerales de los
que más de la mitad ya se sabe que están
entre estos que están en riesgo y que
aparecen en rojo naranja y amarillo en
la en la diapositiva
de hecho hace unos meses cuando estaba
en un curso
y nos preguntaban que qué porcentaje de
la naturaleza estaba a nuestro alrededor
en el aula en el que estaba en nuestras
ciudades en un habla que podría ser como
este auditorio con hormigón con plástico
metal y las respuestas fueron que el 17
el 80 el 90 por ciento y lo cierto es
que es el cien por cien de donde el sino
acaso sacamos los los materiales para
producir todo lo que tenemos a nuestro
alrededor de otro planeta las gracias
que no están a nuestro alrededor aunque
a veces parece que nos cuesta
identificar de dónde viene cada cosa
y es que no tenéis la sensación de que
hemos perdido el vínculo con la
naturaleza yo cada vez tengo más la
sensación de que
y hemos dejado de valorar todo lo que
está a nuestro alrededor y toda la
sabiduría que acumulada a la naturaleza
durante millones de años y sobre todo lo
mucho que dependemos de ella
y ante un contexto como el que vivimos
en el que ya sabemos que los recursos
escaseará en el futuro
parece que necesitamos un cambio de
paradigma diferentes niveles verdad
pues entonces parece lógico pensar que
ocurriría si en vez de lineal nuestra
economía fuera circular y todo lo que
consideramos residuos no fuera otra cosa
que el nutriente o la materia prima del
siguiente de la siguiente forma de vida
del siguiente proceso de tal manera que
la palabra residuo ni siquiera existiera
pues esto es lo que propone con lo que
aspira la economía circular un modelo en
el que no existe residuo porque todo se
mantiene en un círculo cerrado
pero
la verdad lo cierto es que los productos
hoy en día no se diseñan para que se
mantengan dentro de un círculo cerrado
de hecho la fase de diseño de un
producto determina en gran medida cuáles
serán los impactos que éste tendrá a lo
largo de todo su ciclo de vida
y de hecho la gente que diseñan si nos
dejan tenemos la oportunidad de decidir
qué materiales utilizaremos de dónde
vendrán si el producto tendrá otras
funcionalidades para poder extender su
vida o si será fácil de desmontar de es
ensamblar para que sea posible
reciclarlo
y esque
de nada vale que recojamos los plásticos
de las playas de los mares si no
pensamos en el origen si no vamos al
origen del problema en cómo se diseñan
los productos y los procesos y sobre
todo si no cambiamos nuestros modelos de
consumo
y esta es una diferencia vital entre el
reciclaje en la economía lineal en que
los los productos no se diseñan para que
sean regenerados y en la economía
circular en el que el reciclaje no es
que sea la solución es que la última de
las opciones
entonces para lograr esta economía
circular parece que lo que necesitamos
es inspiración verdad es inspiración
tecnología e innovación y parece mentira
que habiendo conviviendo con semejante
cantidad con esta toda esta red de
plantas microbios y animales que han
evolucionado durante casi cuatro mil
millones de años desde la primera
bacteria no los hayamos tomado ya como
ejemplo no esto es lo que hace
precisamente la biomímesis
la biomímesis es la ciencia que estudia
los modelos de la naturaleza y los imita
de mula para resolver problemas humanos
y es que la innovación utilizando la
biomímesis empieza con una palabra muy
simple pero vital y es que haría la
naturaleza aquí que haría para resolver
este problema
y la bio inspiración se puede aplicar en
realidad en todos los ámbitos y existen
ejemplos realmente increíbles
sabéis para pensó alguna vez cómo
resuelve la naturaleza el tema de las
bacterias ya sabemos que las bacterias
son un problema a nivel sanitario sobre
todo a nivel en el ámbito hospitalario
pues las la piel de los tiburones de las
islas galápagos cuenta con un patrón
microscópico que es capaz de evitar la
reproducción bacteriana y de hecho ya es
aplicado en superficies hospitalarias
evitando hasta el 86 por ciento de las
bacterias y sin ningún tipo de otro tipo
de producto adicional para evitarlo y
hablando de grandes animales marinos
aves pensó alguna vez como las ballenas
son capaces de desplazarse con tanta
facilidad en el agua siendo uno de los
animales más grandes del planeta la
ballena jorobada cuenta en sus aletas
como con una especie de protuberancias
que le permiten disminuir la fricción en
el agua y que a su puesto
un gran avance en la dinámica de fluidos
porque permite diseñar las palas de los
aerogeneradores por ejemplo y aumentar
la producción de energía en un 20 por
ciento y reducir fricciones y ruidos
otro ejemplo muy curioso ahí vemos al
avión
otro ejemplo muy curioso es el del
escarabajo del desierto de namibia
este pequeño animal es capaz de
este este pequeño animal es capaz de
capturar del aire el 12 por ciento de su
peso en agua
y lo extrae del aire cada mañana se sube
se sube a la duna se coloca frente al
viento
y captura a la humedad del agua de la
niebla perdón del aire mediante unas
protuberancias que tienen en su
caparazón luego se inclina hacia
adelante y el agua se desliza hacia su
cabeza y puede verlo
esta solución ya se ha aplicado en zonas
con deficiencia hídrica mediante telas
que capturan el agua de la niebla y ha
tenido múltiples aplicaciones como en
invernaderos o en actividades agrícolas
otro ejemplo muy curioso de por qué la
naturaleza puede ser nuestra mejor
mentora es el co2 que es el co2 para el
ser humano
el co2 pues es algo vamos prácticamente
veneno verdad
pues es que todos tenemos la idea de que
el co2 que se produce que producimos con
los coches los aviones con todas las
industrias ha sido el causante de dañar
la capa de ozono y del cambio climático
verdad y que es para la naturaleza pues
la naturaleza
hace cosas como la siguiente los
moluscos capturan el carbono y fabrican
con ellos sus conchas y los corales
capturan también este co2 y lo
convierten en arrecifes
situados imaginados por un momento en
este bosque
en este bosque
os habéis parado a pensar que son como
son de complejos y de simples a la vez
los bosques los bosques son ecosistemas
en los que las estaciones del año y los
ciclos de los animales están en absoluta
armonía cuando paseo por uno de estos
bosques en galicia o en cualquier otro
lugar
veo cientos de materiales y química por
todos lados
pero sin contaminación sin ruido y
cuando cuando veo un árbol muerto no veo
de un residuo de la materia para la
siguiente forma de vida
veo una cadena de suministro infinita de
nutrientes de agua de energía
la madera se convierte en hongos que
alimentan los ratones de campo y que a
su vez alimenta a otro tipo de aves de
aves es local es seguro y es cíclico
seguro que sí si no ahora de pequeños
os habéis quedado impresionados con los
colores de las mariposas y de los de las
plumas de los pavos reales por ejemplo
pues lo curioso es que estos colores no
se necesitan ningún tipo de tinte ni de
química para producirse se producen a
través de la luz que atraviesa
diferentes capas transparentes
estructuras transparentes que
dependiendo de cuánta distancia tengan
entre ellas y cuánto aire pues son
capaces de generar un color u otro os
imagináis qué ocurriría si pudiéramos
cambiar los colores de nuestros
productos simplemente cambiando la
estructura pues este es el tipo de
soluciones que permiten la biomímesis
si pudiéramos reescribir la historia de
las cosas como creéis que sería
seguramente con muy poco residuo verdad
pero lo cierto es que los procesos de
fabricación actualmente son poco
eficientes y en el caso por ejemplo de
los
de los productos realizados con metal
parten de un trozo de material al que se
le va eliminando partes sedes vastas o
tenéis la pieza final la economía
circular
perdón la fabricación aditiva o la
impresión 3d
es un
metodología relativamente nueva y lo que
permite es depositando capas en un
modelo tridimensional y de forma
controlada
conseguir nuevas formas lo hace con un
90 de horno de material sin necesidad de
pillajes y sin desperdicio ninguno
y es que la economía circular perdón la
biomímesis junto con la fabricación
aditiva parece que tienen un campo de
posibilidades realmente enorme porque
modificando las estructuras de un
producto podríamos obtener por ejemplo
unas zapatillas de diferente color
y cambiar la forma o la adaptabilidad a
diferentes terrenos de la suela o
incluso hacerla antibacteriana y es que
estamos ante una nueva revolución
industrial
pero tendremos que preguntarnos si
queremos que tenga los mismos impactos
que las anteriores o si será realmente
biocompatible
con el resto de seres vivos del planeta
y es que ya hemos visto que un mundo
sostenible ya existe
pero tenemos que pero se trata de emular
no solo las formas sino también los
mecanismos y las estrategias de la
naturaleza en nuestros diseños y sobre
todo de hacer ese cambio de mentalidad
que nos permita valorar la naturaleza no
solo por lo que podemos extraer
domesticar sino por todo lo que podemos
aprender de ella
la economía circular y la biomímesis las
posibilidades que tienen son reales no
son una utopía lo que es una utopía es
creer que los recursos seguirán siendo
indefinidos y que podremos seguir
expoliando la tierra de forma indefinida
gracias